über die not der künstler möchte ich mit
marion möglich alias mary die kennen wir
aus dem fernsehen sprechen sie sich das
zugeschaltet sie singt auch am
ballermann hat diverse hits dort hallo
maria
hallo hey wie ist die stimmung im moment
sie sind nicht in spanien haben sie
jetzt gerade wenig zu tun oder wie
stellt sich die lage da aus ihrer sicht
ja also schlagen ist natürlich momentan
nicht machbar bei dem ihr könig noch
geschlossen hat es ist aber so dass ich
versuche aus der not eine tugend zu
machen und das irgendwie gucken dass wir
jetzt mit gartenpartys irgendwie zu den
fans fahren dass wir trotzdem den leuten
das gefühl geben ihr seid nicht alleine
wir halten zusammen und wir machen
irgendwie es besser als zusammen raus
ich glaube das ist so das wichtigste was
wir gerade machen müssen und können
ja und wann glauben sie geht es dann
wieder los ist da in diesem jahr noch
eine chance also ehrlich gesagt ich sehe
momentan gar nicht so die große chance
weil einfach alles noch so gar nicht im
griff ist irgendwie dass man sagen kann
dass mich vorstellen kann dass 1000
leute stehen um die händler streben und
mitfeiern
weil einfach alles irgendwie jeder zeit
in jeder sekunde kippen kann und das
risiko gehen wir alle ein und ich glaube
einfach dass wenn mallorca jetzt aus
machen würde und es wird irgendwie zum
eklat kommen ist es natürlich eine
krasse geschichte dass er hier ist und
ob da und da ist und da habe ich
natürlich auch riesen respekt und angst
vor und wie alle weil unser beruf für
unseren job unser geld hängt daran
und ja ich möchte lieber das alles jetzt
ganz langsam aufgebaut wie zu schnell
und nachher ist wieder ende für alle
tatsächlich wie ist das denn beim thema
alkohol dass das konzert geht normalos
vielleicht aber dann fließt natürlich
gerade auch an der playa de palma dann
der alkohol und dann ist es dann
schwierig mit den abstandsregelung ich
glaube das ist die gefahr die sie
aussehen oder genau das ding ist ja
unsere besteht ja dass die leute spaß
haben dass sie teil
der alkohol mit dazu dass sie an dieser
gefahren urlaub wir wollen irgendwie
jetzt spaß haben wir wollen frei sein
die arbeit vergessen und da trinken
natürlich die leute auch was und dann
natürlich an gewissen pegel an zu denken
'oh ich muss abstand halten
das ist fast unmöglich weil wenn man
wirklich drei feiern ist es mit der
maske nicht machbar und frei feiern
heißt auch nicht irgendwie sich der
einschränken zu lassen und das wird das
problem sein bei uns in der branche
natürlich wie sieht es aus in concert
rein da ist es ja so dass viele leute
sagen wenn ich draußen kann ich mir
vielleicht noch vorstellen aber
tatsächlich in räumen oder hallen kann
ich mir im moment nicht vorstellen zum
konzert zu gehen ist das auch vielleicht
eine barriere im kopf dass die leute
auch dauerhaft sagen wie ich kaufe jetzt
gar keine konzertkarten ich gehe da auch
gar nicht im moment hin ich sagen kann
ist dessen irgendwie sagen dass die
leute irgendwie auseinander oder genug
wechsel mit strandkörben oder sonstigen
sachen aber ich glaube einfach dass auch
mit autokinos dass es so langsam
rückgängig ist weil die leute wollen ja
ich sagen oder bayern steht ja dafür
dass man abschalten kann und wenn man
immer so im hintergrund die korona
geschichte hat mit den masken oder mit
dem verstand es ist schon eine enorme
belastung für alle mal wieder eine
verantwortung auch trägt und ich glaube
das recht ein anderes auto kann dies ja
nicht normal fahren nicht nur wir gehen
auch keine party weil uns das nicht frei
genug ist wenn man halt so eingeschränkt
ist und seiner in seiner eigenen
freiheit sie haben ja vermutlich
deswegen jetzt kaum einnahmen haben sie
sich mal überlegt was anderes zu machen
oder halten sie jetzt knallhart durch ja
also ich sage wir müssen ja alle an
einem strang ziehen deswegen habe ich
diese garten tat ist ein bisschen ins
leben gerufen der sache okay leute wir
machen natürlich nicht den preis welchen
um eingebucht werden sondern wir machen
irgendwie das für alle fair ist für euch
da draußen für die fans für uns künstler
auch dass wir uns trotzdem weiter sehen
können dass sie sagen wir feiern
trotzdem zusammen wir sehen uns weiter
und ich weiss gestern beim lotto am
samstag bei einer gartenparty und ich
denke so überstehen wir das gemeinsam am
besten so dass wir alle
doch das gefühl zum künstler mund zu den
fans weiter doch in den garten party ist
wirklich eine tolle sache das heißt also
sie bieten faire preise an das würde
jetzt vielleicht 1 1 da der den wir
vielleicht in größeren hallen sehen
vielleicht nicht machen aber sie machen
das ihn ist es dann egal ob sie dann vor
20 leuten auftreten oder genau ich sage
immer wir sind uns für nichts zu schade
bei der party oder partykünstler liegen
von unserem publikum und japan sowie all
die jahre gegeben
wir können jetzt die zurückgehenden der
zeitung sagen passt auch wenn ihm nicht
die volle gage
wir machen ja wirklich irgendwie so dass
wir kommen können und dass wir mit euch
feiern können und es gibt die zeit
irgendwie fläche wird normal gebucht und
ich sehe bei uns im garten die mary und
ich glaube dass es den zusammenhalt des
feeling müssen wir ihnen jetzt rüber
bringen es ist glaube ich ganz wichtig
viele künstler haben bei uns in der
sendung ja auch schon drüber gesprochen
die rechne nicht damit dass in diesem
jahr noch weiter geht jetzt haben wir
schon gehört
die gerade die deutschsprachige sänger
machen sich sorgen auch schon über
karneval auch das wird natürlich in
geschlossenen räumen statt wie glauben
sie wird zum ende des jahres
ich denke auch also diese ganz ganz
schwierig weil es glaube ich auch ein
schwieriges thema ich hoffe dass es
irgendwie stattfindet aber auch da
wieder aber kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen weil das ist dasselbe bild
wie einen großen august dicht an dicht
stehen da muss man dabei sein er positiv
ist so sachsens trick mehrere die bälle
geht wieder los und so weiter und so
fort also ich würde es mir wünschen aber
ich sehe dem ganzen realistisch auch ins
auge und sagt ich freue mich auf
bookings lenzen kann aber es kommt aber
jetzt erst mal denke ich für dieses jahr
wird es wirklich ganz ganz schwer
umkämpft frage ich dazu noch mal was
können künstler machen nach idee ist
tatsächlich auf ja im prinzip auf
honorar verzichten und klein weiter zu
machen was würden sie künstlern
empfehlen
also das ist natürlich eine gute gute
situation aber ich möchte immer so ein
bisschen davor waren selbst auch zu
veranstalten
denn wir haben eine veranstalter haftung
und das kann dann immer ein bisschen
kritisch werden ich wie gesagt so ist
man jetzt sagt natürlich jeder ja der
anwalt immer aber das ist ja genau mein
meinen job dass ich in dieser situation
natürlich immer ein bisschen auch die
gefahren hinweisen muss ich möchte da
jetzt gar nicht unken oder so aber es
besteht als voran der veranstalter
haftung und da habe ich immer so ein
bisschen bauchschmerzen dabei wenn wir
so die anfragen haben
auch von künstlern die das bisher noch
nicht gemacht haben da muss man sich
sehr genau mit befassen wenn man selbst
veranstaltet also wenn man selbst karten
beispielsweise verkauft selbst eine
kleine veranstaltung macht dann muss man
doch sehr darauf achten dass der eben
nichts passiert und wenn was passiert
dann haben wir durchaus eine haftung und
das ist dann sehr riskant also von daher
kann ich wirklich nur sagen auch gerade
in diesem kleinen bereich muss man das
ist eine tolle idee tolle sache aber
bitte auch immer so ein bisschen die
rechts grefrath im auge behalten aber es
war wichtig das zu sagen ja ich möchte
dazu sagen da uns ist so dass die ich
viele gartenpartys gebucht werde das
heißt ist veranstaltet jemand was und
sagt ich mache eine große gartenparty
die buchen mary dazu das heißt ich fahr
dahin mache meinen auftritt und fahren
auch wieder die genehmigung selber
besorgen
die müssen natürlich auch mit nachbarn
sprechen und so weiter das wissen sie
alle
wir bringen würde ich es nicht gut mit
und sorgen für die technik und wir
werden zu der veranstaltung hin gebucht
also ich selber nicht bei mir zu hause
oder organisiert keine veranstaltung
sondern ich werde dahin gebucht wie zu
normalen veranstaltung aber auch wenn
einem eine veranstaltung ist sonst war
also das scheint alles zu sein was
müsste ich bezahlen und mary bei mir im
garten zu haben ja wir haben momentan
liegen so circa bei also wir sind jetzt
schon mit 1000 euro ungefähr wir machen
gehören auch bei einer gage aber wir
haben gesagt wir müssen jetzt wirklich
die zeit nutzen wir möchten nicht so
viel verlangen auf unter die hälfte noch
runter und ich denke so ist für jeden
machbar wenn es zusammen liegen und so
könne man diesen partys sommer zusammen
haben naja da bleibt nicht ganz so viel
hängen aber tatsächlich wenn sie mario
deswegen war sie natürlich auch wenn er
sein ein bisschen werbung auch in
eigener sache zu machen wenn sie mary im
garten haben wollen 4000 euro sind sie
dabei wünschen ihnen viel erfolg dass es
irgendwann auch wieder mehr kohle zu
verdienen gibt vielen dank dass sie in
der sendung waren